Good morning, John!
I don't know if you've heard about this yet,
but there is a hip new challenge going on
on YouTube right now and I am super interested
in it.
It's called the "Explain the 2008 Financial
Crisis in Less Than Sixty Seconds" Challenge,
so I'm gonna try to do it!
Interest rates in 2008 were super low, which
meant that banks could basically borrow money
for free, so they had tons of potential money,
but they needed stuff to buy, and the most
important new thing to buy turned out to be
people's mortgages because there were more
than thirteen trillion dollars of them.
There are four institutions that are important
to this story: lenders who made the loans;
investment banks who bought, packaged, and
resold the loans; ratings agencies who told
investors how risky the loans were; and investors
who bought the loans from the banks.
Because of this new system, a bunch of people
did a bunch of things they should not have
done.
Lenders didn't need to worry about whether
the loans would be paid off anymore because
they were just selling the loans off, and
because there was so much demand, they started
to create manipulative loans that they gave
to people who could never pay them off.
Those sub-prime loans were purchased by investment
banks who did a number of duplicitous things
to make rating agencies think that they were
not sub-prime loans.
They were rated as AAA and investors bought
them, thinking that they were getting a good
thing, and eventually, when the inevitable
happened and people couldn't pay off their
loans, the entire house of lies came crashing
down, along with a good portion of the global
economy.
Wooooo!
Challenge complete!
And now I got like, three minutes left of
this video, so...
I should do some more challenges!?
There's a bunch of good ones.
The "Grow A Bunch of Hair" Challenge!
Each of my 150,000 hair follicles produces
around .44 millimeters of hair per day, meaning
that in total, I grow around 0.29 inches of
hair per second.
Over the course of a day, if all of my hair
growth were concentrated on one hair, that
hair would be 220 feet long!
So while you can't see hair grow, you do grow
a lot of it.
The "Try to Make A Harpsichord Noise Challenge".
Bing gang ba-ding gang bwang gang bwang da-dang
ding dong tcka-tck ting tong tang.
The "Drink However Much Mouthwash You Have
Left" Challenge.
I should have bought a smaller bottle... ugh.
It's the challenge though.
[alarm noise] It's just water with food coloring
in it, come on!
The "Make Breakfast on Snapchat" Challenge!
[music]
The "How Loud Can You Scream" Challenge.
AHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
The "Apologize For Something While You're
Doing It" Challenge.
I don't dislike challenge videos, I actually
quite like them; I think they're fun, and
I think it's difficult to come up with good
ideas for challenges and to have a good time
and edit together good challenge videos.
I don't want this video to be seen as mocking
challenge videos, but instead re-thinking
that genre to fit my own aesthetic.
The "How Many Jump Cuts Can You Have In One
Sentence" Challenge.
And finally, the "How Far Up Your Body Can
You Bite?"
Challenge.
Ahhh.
Grahh.
Ehh.
Yeah.
Oh, does this count?
Like omm arrr ahhh.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Only a week until the Project For Awesome
starts.
This day!
Next week.
It will begin!
There will be a live stream.
It will be great!
And fun!
You should join us.
Put aside a little bit of your schedule.
If you want to make a video that people can
vote on and your favorite charity might get
a whole bunch of money, you can do that, and
maybe put a little bit of your money aside
too, because there's going to be a bunch of
really cool perks!
A-doot-doot-doot!